how's Gomer as manosphere I found this
awesome app and you can do some
sculpturing in it you bro suggested it
so let's see what we can create all
right we have a great base now let's
start by giving some good ice okay that
looks very good so far
let's put a smile on that face you don't
want to mess up the face too much though
but if you want a great face you got a
sacrifice this kind of looks like Homer
Simpson all right let's do Homer Simpson
oh my god
this is actually good don't [ __ ] up the
knows how God we [ __ ] it up then we
apparently Homer Simpson has leprosy
that's great
Homer Simpson became Michael Jackson in
two seconds fantastic this is a little
harder than I thought
so nothing to smooth out the skin a
little bit all right you know what it's
not gonna get any better
so let's color him up looks great I
can't be the only one who thinks this is
extremely erotic oh my god
it's practically over that's all so I
think we did a great job all right so
some of you suggested pit bull I don't
know why I don't really know how he
looks like uh I just know he's kind of
grows in bold so yeah we're done
actually needs to be chubbier
immediately getting more there it was
just one thing with an eye like he's
like oh yeah his eyes are in fact the
very poppy let's bring out the eye
goddamn it let's bring out the eyes a
little bit all right that looks like a
cow nipple inside of an eye that's
that's great this is really turning me
on I have a sudden urge to lick him his
face is very small need to bring down
his entire skull
a lot that's a great shape and he's very
close to his neck like a not just close
but I hear he has a close relationship
going on
let's give him a couple of those famous
chin Chin's let's not forget his
fantastic eyebrows there we go a little
in between there let's uh let's do
colouring let's go with a nice yellowish
color
so which pitbull song is your favorite
that is actually a trick questions
they're all the same
get that perv mustache in there I feel
like I forgot something
oh yeah his lips are really red I don't
know what's up with that but they are he
has these like random dots all over his
face I think they're freckles but I also
think they could be a sign of Illuminati
and we have a pitbull ladies in rez
pretty good sculpture if I may say so
myself he has about over 9 million chins
something to take home and show to your
mom
all right someone came with a great
suggestion to do handsome Squidward so
let's do that all right this will be a
challenge Jesus Christ
gotta get that good bass going you know
alright so so far I think we've done a
great job at making it not resemble
handsome Squidward at [ __ ] all looks
fantastic so far I must say it's a very
prominent ball sack under his chin if
you have a great feature you obviously
want to show it off to the world Jesus
Christ what happened either Squidward
has AIDS or or lepers I don't even know
alright so now for the feature that I'm
a little terrified of and that is the
ice simple see how this goes not too
shabby
not too shabby oh god that's that's
really [ __ ] close man
alright let's be honest it's not gonna
get any better it's mr. let's color that
[ __ ]
and there you have it I thoroughly
enjoyed making that that was awesome I
hope I can make another one once I
learned this program or it's really fun
I didn't expect to enjoy it that much
all right I spent a little too much time
with that well let's try one more
all right so way too many of you suggest
that I do a cry face I guess I have to
do it all right it's even out that face
a lot oh look I can ride my signature on
his face fantastic how do we how are we
gonna do this there we go how the [ __ ]
am I supposed to do this oh my god so
good alright that will have to do and
there we have it my god I am so proud of
myself for making this thing alright
let's save it and never look at it again
thank you very much her eyebrows I had
on a surprising about a fun sculpturing
so if she wanted me to do more go ahead
and leave a like and leave a comment
saying who I should sculpture or what I
bet you're surprised there was no
penises aren't you you little perv
anyway stay awesome bros but i know you
will